are people born gay and what on earth
does science have to say about this
that's the question I'd like to dive
into today my name is Brett sulfur
pastor at the table at church in sexy
Texas and this is Table Talk where each
week I impact ideas and insights from
Christian theology and spirituality that
help you become a more thoughtful calm
and just a wonderful human being so we
are in part six of my series titled why
I'm a gay affirming Christian and so
let's go ahead and jump into our topic
for today nice I want to begin with a
quote from the American Psychological
Association in its article titled sexual
orientation and homosexuality was
published in August of 2017 and ago
there is no consensus among scientists
about the exact reasons that an
individual develops a heterosexual
bisexual gay or lesbian orientation
although much research has examined the
possible genetic hormonal developmental
social and cultural influences on sexual
orientation no findings have emerged
that permit scientists to conclude that
sexual orientation is determined by any
particular factor or factors many think
that nature and nurture both play
complex roles most people experience
little or no sense of choice about their
sexual orientation okay so the reason I
like this quote is that it draws out the
fact that while scientists have learned
quite a bit over the years about sexual
orientation it it's true that it's
basically far from some sort of like
closed case for example we used to think
that genes basically determined
everything about a person like I'm
thinking 20-30 years ago so many
scientists were looking
for the gaijin but what scientists have
learned is that it's not an all that
simple because of something called
epigenetics epigenetics is the basically
the science of the study of of the
environment and its impact on genes
themselves for example you may have
genes that would make you statistically
more likely to develop for various forms
of cancer however if you live a healthy
life with plenty of exercise and a good
diet it's very possible that the
environment of your body will never
actually turn those genes on sort of
activate them in other words genes are
not what we thought they were 30 years
ago they are not your destiny in that
fact has played a major role in people
who study same gender sexuality because
now all of a sudden we realize oh it's
not as simple as pointing to like the
one or the two were the three gay genes
that determine someone's sexual
orientation now this is key though not
because genetic influences don't exist
we know that they do but we realize now
that environment plays a major role in
how those genes function and whether
they get turned off or on alright now
when folks hear the language of
environment they immediately jump to the
whole nature-nurture debate and they say
oh okay I get it by environment you mean
how a gay person like was raised you
know so if you're gay you probably had a
smothering mother or a incredibly
distant or abusive father
you know that's environment not so much
actually there's not really any great
data pointing out that's something like
you know parenting contributes to
people's sexual orientation
instead authors dr. Glenn Wilson and dr.
quasi Raman in their book born gay the
psycho biology of sexual orientation
point to the fact that numerous studies
done in the last 50 years point to
genetic and hormonal influences that
combine to powerfully influence a
person's sexual orientation for example
in their review of the literature on
this topic Wilson and Raman point out
that as a male your chances of being
born gay rise substantially 33 percent
for every male that has previously
inhabited your mother's womb in other
words if you're the firstborn son then
statistically you have a 2% chance of
being born gay if you're the sixth son
[Music]
then you have a six percent chance of
being gay now that may not sound like a
lot from 2% to 6% but honestly if you
think about it your odds just tripled
now you say well perhaps you know that's
because of like the impact of having a
lot of brothers you know maybe the sixth
son is like more likely to be bullied or
something um however one study actually
looked into this and they found that a
man's chances increased even if he was
raised apart from his older brothers
similarly the trend did not hold true in
families where there were a number of
adopted younger brothers that would seem
to point to something about the
environment of a mother's womb in terms
of influencing sexual orientation
okay so why exactly is this honestly
scientists don't yet know for sure but
at this point it looks to have something
to do with the fact that when a woman
gets pregnant with her first boy that a
certain type of protein is released into
her bloodstream and then her body then
develops antibodies against that protein
which through a complex process can then
later cross the placental barrier and
influence the brain development of a
developing male fetus okay so that's
just one set of you know studies another
set of studies show a very strong
correlation between very young boys who
want to play with dolls and really young
girls who want to you know like play
football and act wild and wrestle and
that they do in fact have extremely high
rates of same-sex attraction later in
life no this is not of course to say
that literally every boy who plays with
dolls or every girl who wants to play
football or something you know ends up
being gay but simply that's
statistically speaking it's absolutely
correlated now this of course makes a
lot of sense in lines up perfectly with
the testimonies of most gay and lesbian
people who they tended to know right if
you talk with them they didn't know from
a relatively young age that they were in
fact different again does that mean
literally every gay person that's their
story no of course not it's just that
statistically it does seem to be
correlated alright finally one other
point that I think seems really relevant
in this conversation is the terrible
failure rates of
a conversion or is it sometimes known
repaired as therapy in 2007 so this is
quite a while ago thirteen years ago a
task force of the American Psychological
Association undertook a thorough review
of the existing research on the efficacy
and an effectiveness of conversion
therapy and their report found that
there was very little methodologically
sound research on sexual orientation
change efforts in that quote the results
of scientifically valid research
indicate that it is unlikely that
individuals will be able to reduce
same-sex attractions or increase other
sex sexual attractions through sexual
orientation change efforts now notably
in the evangelical Christian like wing
of the world the ministry known as
Exodus this was the single largest
Christian reparative therapy Center in
the u.s. shut down in 2013 because its
leader Allen chambers basically admitted
that in short it didn't work
co-founder Michael bussy he left Exodus
in 1979 and he later admitted this is a
quote from him I never saw one of our
members or other Exodus leaders or other
Exodus members become heterosexual so
deep down he said I knew that it wasn't
true now what the shows is that
regardless of where exactly scientists
sort of end up falling as far as the
whole nature-nurture debate in the
coming years the ability for LGBTQ
people to as some folks crudely put it
prey of the gay away this is not a
viable option and in fact reparative
therapy can be quite dangerous because
it often leads to feelings of
self-loathing increased rates of
depression and even increased rates of
suicide so all that to say although
there's a lot of research that needs to
be done the last 40 to 50 years of
research seems to be pointing much more
strongly in the direction of nature when
it comes to development of someone's
sexual orientation however that's not to
like rule out the fact that environment
social convention may well play a part
in the process so if you'd like more
info on this topic I highly encourage
you to grab Wilson and ramens book born
gay
it's an excellent one on this topic so
that is all for today if you enjoyed
this video please like it share it
comment and subscribe bye even go
subscribe on YouTube by going there and
searching bretzel for tabletalk or
pretty much anywhere podcasts are
offered on there as well so much love
you'll have a great week grace in peace